let's go
let's go to noah from california noah
you're on the air
hi can you hear me yes i can
all right hey david a long time listener
first time caller thank you uh i just
had a uh
question if if you've noticed i heard
you talk the other day that you said
crypto seems to be a trigger word for a
lot of people on the left
and i
feel like i've been seeing that happen
with tesla and elon musk as well people
trying to
uh
bag on his engineering of the vehicles
and saying that it's badly designed this
i mean i thought we were supposed to be
pro electric vehicle right yeah i just i
don't understand it
yeah i mean listen i i don't know that
i'm the right person to comment on this
as both a you know tesla vehicle owner
and long-time shareholder i quite
frankly couldn't care less about elon
musk i mean you know um
my car has been perfect there's no
problems with it it works fine every
feature works fine i've never had any
problem the car needs no maintenance
it has
you know
we most vehicle manufacturers
doing electric vehicles
still don't have vehicles with range
anywhere close to what tesla has but i
do agree
that soon
tesla's going to have a problem on its
hands um one of those problems is that i
mean listen audi is better at making
cars than tesla
that's just the reality and right now
the audi e-tron gets 200 miles
per charge but later this year they're
gonna have one that gets closer to 400
miles per charge once that's the case
are people going to get the e-tron or
the model y i mean probably the e-tron
you know so so i think that there's
legitimate criticisms of the vehicles
there's criticisms of the company the
company is getting sued for certain
things and everything should all happen
i don't really care about the cult of
personality stuff i mean i think uh
you know elon musk needs to pay taxes
and elon musk needs to
do all the things everybody needs to do
but yeah for me it's like people just
get so emotional about this stuff it's
like i don't care about elon musk i
don't care about sergey brin or
zuckerberg specifically it's just sort
of like what are these companies doing
what are they bringing to the table are
they properly regulated etc elon musk's
wacky tweets yeah i find them stupid but
i just don't really care you know
right right i pretty much agree with
everything there i just have a quick
follow-up what do you think about these
uh electric trucks coming out i think it
was ford or chevron or something that
just released them uh do you have any
opinions about that would you be getting
an electric truck if given the
opportunity i don't need a truck i mean
you know growing up i had friends who
had pickup trucks and i would always say
what do you need the bed for and they'd
say oh every once in a while i move
something
i just don't i just don't need a truck
so i don't plan to get a truck but i
think it's fantastic and the fact that
there's such demand for the electric
f-150 bodes really well for electric
vehicle adoption um i i think it's great
i think we just need to be moving
towards electric vehicles period
completely agree thank you david for
answering my call my pleasure there is
noah with some very pointed questions
about
tesla
and
and other things